[Music]
hey you guys
look tom's got a hat on yeah
i did um i did a two mile [ __ ] ruck
march
i came back i'm all [ __ ] sweaty she's
like you're stinking i know you sat
there and i was just like
damn dude so i went in there and got
some damn
obsession he drenched himself in the
recession
man the bottom of my feet [ __ ] tender
as [ __ ] man i got
getting soft i know it's toughing
everything up man that's why i see the
bottom of my feet are really tough
because it felt good because i walk all
the time
i had like a 70 probably between like a
70 and 75 pound rucksack
and uh it felt good to do that two miles
with that weight on there it's just the
bottom of my feet
[ __ ] tender it'll they didn't bless
her but they it'll hurt worse tomorrow
i'm telling you i'm gonna do it tomorrow
no i'm saying that your feet will hurt
like when you wake up tomorrow yeah
you know what i'm saying that's gonna be
my lower body workout yeah
just just pile more and more weight on
on
these carry be able to carry like a
[ __ ] 100 pound ruck
yeah just the rock was 100 pounds yeah
yeah
cross country climbing [ __ ] hills and
[ __ ]
yeah i could do it now but probably just
as easy probably easier
i probably can condition that pretty
good i'm stronger now than i was i don't
have the endurance but
i can build that up fourth drawer down
says you need a rocky montage
yeah but it's a monster no it's actually
not
not rocky would be more like [ __ ] um
it would be more like [ __ ] on conan
the damn
[ __ ] crucible of crap forging the
[ __ ] sword and [ __ ]
and then going around the wheel
like that yeah yeah you want to do
uh the shout out yeah cause i see i see
sophie there and the thing
here we got a big box yesterday morning
a christmas present from sophie no it
didn't come yesterday
today no did came did it came this
morning it was yes yes it was yesterday
morning or maybe
this morning i think it was this morning
i don't remember early this morning
got two different kinds of of um
kayla kayla kayla this is good stuff too
man
i bet i keep seeing that at the store
haven't had that
and then here's the other one small
batch
tequila yeah nice all right i don't
think you've tried it in one of these
now
this i actually saw it in the liquor
store the other day and i was like
intrigued but i didn't buy it but here
it is it's caramel blueball peanut
butter
whiskey yeah which i was like ooh that
sounds delightful
and what here i had that grape what was
that grapes
of sour what was that [ __ ] no the um
what do you think i
don't know i think i threw that [ __ ]
away schnapps had that grape schnapps
yeah i got that for you a long time ago
when we had this yeah it's been sitting
there for about six years and i i kind
of was like i was wondering because it
had been opened
yeah like madam worth it that shit's
probably not good anymore so just threw
it out to be safe
yeah and then that shows up it's
probably good yeah it's not expensive
it's not all right now i think it's like
a few books i mean but
and then look this is like godiva
chocolate liqueur
so see i'm imagining that if you combine
these two things
that it'll taste like an alcoholic
reese's peanut butter cup and i'm all
over that action
yes it's not there in the bar so
nah dude it was pucker great pucker yeah
that's what it was i got you
yeah i got you that like a long time ago
and we just didn't drink all of it
because like i said we ran out of peanut
butter and jelly vodka before we ran out
of the great pucker that's what we
bought it for
but uh yeah it's it's easy to get you
can get some more
but yeah sophie said uh tara mana is
dwayne johnson's brand
oh is it i thought you'd want to try it
yeah give it an opinion i didn't even
know yeah see
that just goes to show rock the rocks
[ __ ] the rocks
tequila
i'm nervous because that's where pookie
jumps up on the desk and yesterday she
jumped up on here and like her little
front paws landed on the
on the mouse pad and she went sliding
back off
and i was like ah poor little baby all
right so
this movie here i'm actually glad that
this was recommended because i don't
think that i would have
sought it out or said because it's on
netflix but it came out a couple years
ago so i guess it just kind of like went
under my radar
but somebody let's see it's got the
rock's [ __ ] signature on the back oh
yeah
yeah i didn't even see that it's agave
roasting
dwayne johnson's signature tequila yeah
it's got all his stuff there
yeah you're gonna have to have some of
that tonight and uh no no i'm not not
tonight
because i don't want you you're gonna
save my birthday i don't have the proper
thing to [ __ ]
uh i don't have any orange juice
because that's a silver i'd probably
want to make a damn uh
sunrise with that taste at first what
i'm talking about yeah
and um that's right so i can get an
accurate
taste of that accurate assessment
if he says it's got to be manly right
[Laughter]
hell yeah that increases your
testosterone
well even just reverses gynecomastia
that's how [ __ ] man so you're gonna
like get rid of your moves
yeah well i don't have gynecomastia you
don't have guidance
you don't actually no you have to
[ __ ] like abuse steroids and you get
gyno he had gyno
yeah and he got that [ __ ] taken off but
if that reverses it have he known
that that must really be that must
really be sad for like a man to be
have gyno anything yeah that'll happen
there's been like oh no like a
gynecologist has got some
womany stuff ew well they're their
hormones
get all [ __ ] [ __ ] up on on on on on
voids and they'll [ __ ] get
sorry they'll start to get a gyno
yeah they need to get a reduction
yeah i gotta get a boob reduction it's a
small procedure it's not a big deal
it's just kind of funny they'll get them
a [ __ ] puffy nipples and [ __ ]
yeah they'll be making fun of each other
why are you nipples so [ __ ] puffy guy
[ __ ] tip [ __ ]
can we please have another shirt that
just says ooh my puffy nipples
and then we'll have like little cotton
puffs or something like [ __ ]
[Laughter]
hormones a hell of a hormone it is i bet
when you clicked on what you thought was
a review
of a very good indonesian action
thriller you didn't know you'd be
hearing the phrase puffy nipples yeah
but that's just one of the services that
we provide here at 13 o'clock podcast
um so yeah so i guess when we did a
review of the other indonesian film this
was like
probably a few weeks or a month ago
called uh may the devil take you too
um that was the same director as this
movie so somebody in the comments of
that movie
said hey here's this other movie and
it's on netflix that came out in 2018
it's the same director
so can you please do a review of that so
i was like sure why not we didn't have
anything planned to do so we watched it
last night it's called the night comes
for us
and uh i can't i'm i'm sure i'm gonna
pronounce the director's name wrong
it's timo uh
ja janto yeah to jaw jonto yeah before
the before this review goes any further
let's say this is a good movie it is
it's a crazy [ __ ] movie
it's uh real gory yeah real violent
right this is this is what happens when
you take them same guys back in the 70s
who are making those [ __ ] kung fu
flicks
you take them you give them modern
technology and then show them john wick
and this is what you get
this one this is getting um compared to
the raid a lot because i think that the
um
that this two of the guys that are in
this movie were also in that movie
it's a gangster movie yeah pretty much
with martial arts and a bunch of
shootouts and [ __ ]
bunch of gore with
hot lesbian chicks in it fighting each
other with swords
swords and a springy thing that like
yeah and they're in like a
they're in like a [ __ ] what do you
call it
interracial relationship between the
asian and caucasian
it's it's been it's [ __ ] banana
vanilla
[Laughter]
exactly going down it's a trip and
that's just
those are just the some of the side
villains
then you got the good guys which are
villains kind of like john wick
and then he's fighting other villains
and then you got dude what was his name
white boy
joey no what was it bobby white boy
bobby he was my favorite character
kind of white he was kind of white you
could tell he was
he was comparatively white he was white
and jason you could tell
it's white yeah and he did some [ __ ]
badass [ __ ] it's just [ __ ] funny
he was a heroin addict with one foot one
foot who could walk
and he'd give him a little bitty knife
and he killed he'd take an unlimited
amount of [ __ ] bullets
but he'd take all kinds of rounds and
survive it [ __ ]
throw dudes out windows and then he'd
stab him up like that
and he's [ __ ] about half [ __ ]
[Laughter]
but it's a serious film it is a serious
film i thought it was a [ __ ]
documentary
i did man i had a lot of fun with this
now like i said if you don't like like
uber uber violent
and i'm i'm just i'm gonna go it's it
goes over the line from violet into
gory it's not a flick it's a film it's a
film
it is i thought scorsese [ __ ] wrote
and [ __ ] did this
i thought it was scorsese maybe even
[ __ ] old wes's name
did have some scorseses i was going damn
louis says you had my attention at hot
lesbians they yeah they don't come into
it until like later on in the movie
worth seeing
okay hollywood does hollywood wouldn't
make a movie like this nowadays this all
this [ __ ] was off the table too toxic
mask
too much toxic masculinity too much
violence too many drugs
too much torture and gore too many
inappropriate lesbians
like you could have lesbians with
birkenstocks and [ __ ] hairy armpits
you can't have lesbians like this these
are like
goth industrial lesbians
[Laughter]
in a tri-racial tri-racial relationship
there's three of them they're trying it
out
that's like but this does well the thing
about it is that as fun as this
is it's like this is basically why
you're watching the movies for the fight
sequences much like
the john wick movies like i said you're
watching and i have to say too that the
fight choreography and the gore in this
is so
so good well the story though is good
too you could tell they were watching
tarantino
there's some tarantino [ __ ] in there
there's some john wick stuff
they're just taking although tarantino
ripped off a bunch of like hong kong
cinema
right they're ripping him back off so
they're ripping him it's like
it's like a daisy chain if you get all
these
people off cluster [ __ ] in a circle
like that that's what you're gonna have
they did it right the guys that made
this move they did it right they knew
what their strengths were
and they they knew how to they knew how
to even kind of ride on their weaknesses
too
like they made that a thing you know
yeah they they knew
they knew exactly what even though this
is indonesian it feels kind of like
real good hong kong but it's well it was
they tell their homage
yeah there was it's weird because it's
like you know it was it was indonesian
an indonesian film but there was some
english spoken in it there was like some
chinese spoken in it there was like all
different kind of [ __ ] going on
because it was kind of like i think most
of it was like set in jakarta
and i can't remember like where else
macau maybe
but yeah so basically the story is
there's this dude
named ito and he was
in okay so i guess like in the triads
there were like these six
like super badass assassin type people
but they
nobody knew who they were like which
ones they were and they were called the
six c's
so he was like one of those and i guess
one of his
assignments was he had he was tasked
with like going to wipe out this whole
entire village
who it was like a little fishing village
and they had been like skimming some
money off of like the
you know because the drugs were coming
in there and they were taking a cut but
they were taking like
more than their cut that they were
supposed to so like the big boss was
like you go in there and take the whole
[ __ ] village out
so ito goes there and does that with his
men but then there's like one little
girl that's left alive this is like the
first five minutes of the movie
um and he decides that he can't kill her
so
he then goes on the run so he then gets
back with
like members of his old crew uh the big
drug dealer like sends
all the villains after him like just he
has endless skins
and that's the boring part that's the
point
yeah the opening act really it didn't
pull me into this
i thought it was like okay i thought it
was starting kind of weak
i was like this is gonna be weak but
little did i know
okay it wraps up yeah like be a little
patient with it because at the beginning
there's like the villagers are wiped out
at the beginning but then like there's
kind of a long extended like him getting
back with
uh you know taking the little girl back
to the gang and then
try they try to establish like a
normalcy
baseline you have like normals you have
normalcy bias at first
oh this is going to be a normal movie
and then the [ __ ] starts kicking in
and it looks insane in comparison so it
was effective
had it started off crazy the craziness
wouldn't have been effective
well you would have gotten bored you're
like wait a minute hold on this crazy
[ __ ] is happening in the real world
that's how it [ __ ] that was how they did
the tone
yeah that's that this crazy [ __ ] is
happening kind of like in
in the real world which is impossible
yeah all right but that's that's the
that's the genius of this movie because
the first
i mean i kind of agree with you too like
i i liked the story but it does like
take a little while to get like real
engaged with the characters and stuff
but then they have i think the first
action sequence is that one of the
butcher shop right yeah
and and then i was like okay i'm on
board with you now
it starts layering one layer of crazy on
top of another layer of crazy
and it keeps going you go this shit's
[ __ ] insane
and it it's it does it in the way
john wick does it the same way it gets
crazier as it goes
yeah like each act actually sequences
more and more
this is like imagine you [ __ ] drop
some acid and it's happening it's even
crazier
they know that they're being crazy but
they're yeah but they're i mean they're
playing it pretty straight it's not zany
or anything no
no i mean other than white boy bobby who
was just who was kind of funny and like
made some like funny comments but it
wasn't like goofball he kind of reminded
me of a tarantino style
character yeah it would be in a
tarantino movie yeah
and um certain scenes was like something
out of a tarantula they were like
self-aware then this this doesn't this
feel like we're in a gangster movie
and it's just [ __ ] funny you know it
didn't have the
useless banter that [ __ ] you know i
mean
yeah it was mostly just there were
serious scenes of like character work
but then
once once you had the big fight in the
butcher shop which was great
then after that it was basically just
like action sequence on action sequence
on action but they kept
ramping up the stakes you know towards
the middle some [ __ ] went down and i
didn't really understand it tried to get
a little sentimental on me
you know what i mean and i i really
i kind of lost track of the story so it
kind of slowed down but that wasn't very
long
maybe bad well because edo like like i
said he left so that's why the
big boss was like you know trying to
bump him off yeah and then but he had a
guy
like that was his he kept calling him
his brother but i guess he was like his
best friend
so they they used to like be in a crew
together like back in the day
and then they both went and joined the
triads but then it wanted to get out and
so now it was kind of like they turned
against each other so you know that
they're gonna have like the big main
battle at the end
because they're kind of like at the end
the big main battle
the fights between the the the two main
dudes
they went on too long it it went on it
it went on too long and it got to where
i was kind of like bored with the fight
scene and then it got a little bit
better because other [ __ ] happened after
that
the ultimate long fights he was between
keith david and [ __ ] rowdy roddy
piper and [ __ ] they live that was the
ultimate
long fight if it's longer than that you
start getting bored
but they were trying to throw each other
on table saws and they were doing [ __ ]
to each other [ __ ] cutting pieces off
of each other
it was good it's just that
maybe you were just having a little bit
of a fatigue yeah the time you got to
the end because that's like
the end of the movie it was like fight
scene fatigue there's the edit should
have been a little tighter i think
some of that [ __ ] should have been cut
out it shouldn't have been that long
yeah i mean the movie was two hours yeah
um
i didn't really feel like two hours to
me but like i could kind of see
i was laughing i mean it's not a comedy
but i was
it's like that damn japanese action
movie that was super
about the guy who goes into prison the
old one like riccio riccio like story of
ricky or yeah
not quite as not quite as over that
one's that one's just
that was insane but you could tell that
they saw that movie
yeah because this one like i said it's
it's not quite to the level of cutting
off someone's arm and like
hitting a [ __ ] with another
[ __ ] you know what i mean it's
not
quite to that extent but jeremiah can do
that
um actually one of my favorites i love
the butcher the butcher shop sequence
cause because i loved that
there was all the blood already because
there's like all this meat hanging and
so all the meat was like incorporated
like into the fight which i thought was
really cool
and i also and you know there's all the
[ __ ] table saws and cleavers and [ __ ]
like that you can do all kind of fun
[ __ ] with
um my other one and i'm not sure you
might have been like you know
in the bathroom or in the kitchen or
something looking for pookie like when
this scene was on
but the scene where edo was in the
armored car like with the corrupt cops
and they were fighting inside that
armored car like this
tiny little space and there was just one
great shot
where he like he like flips this dude
over the thing and then like he takes
his arm and his arm just like bends all
the way backward like over the side of
this it was so great
they must have had yeah they must have
had people with their missing limbs to
do something or that was just like a
fake arm and they had
his other one under there i don't know
but it looked really good there was you
could tell some of this [ __ ] was cg but
it seemed like most of it was practical
it looked like most of it was practical
they asked me if the lesbians were
sentimental no the lesbians were not
saying that
the lesbians were villains the lesbians
were they were some of the gangsters
like
gangsters yes i've called them
inappropriate lesbians because they're
obviously fake lesbians
they're the kind of lesbians that are in
like [ __ ] asian
porn or something you know they were
they were like some
it was like some dude from hong kong's
conception of the way
some kind of gothic lesbians would be
yeah
it's [ __ ] crazy you said i'm talking
about yeah i know what you're talking
about yeah
straight girls pretending to be lesbians
being directed by straight men
on how to be a lesbian you'll see what
i'm talking about
yeah they are they did a lot of cool
fights
the fight choreography in this is really
good yeah um i saw another review of
this and i did it didn't occur to me
until they said this but somebody said
that some of the fight scenes like the
camera shots and stuff
like because you know how in some of the
fights like the camera shots like follow
the person like when they're falling and
stuff
that was to kind of like um upgrade yeah
that was that you know they had some
kind of camera shots i have a reminder
to see that again i think sophie sent me
upgrade i think yeah yeah yeah
that was a [ __ ] great movie but yeah
somebody compared they said you know
that
some of the shots were kind of the same
because they were like particularly one
of the last
scenes where edo was like fighting all
these dudes like in a big pool hall or
something
and um for for a little while like the
camera looked like it was like right on
the back like on the back of his head or
something like that or he was like on a
dolly
and it was because it was kind of like
weirdly distorted and [ __ ] like that
they didn't do i like that they didn't
do a lot of that but they just did like
enough of it to keep everything
interesting and like i said the the
fight choreography was so good
and the way it was shot was really good
like you could cut it was really fast
paced and crazy and everybody's like
flipping around and stuff
but you could tell where everybody was
and you could tell what was happening
you know what i'm saying because i think
there's because having good fight
choreography and having people filming
it correctly are two separate things
fourth drawer down is recommended that
we see uh what's it called what do you
say
legends legend of the seven golden
vampire i think we saw that one i think
yeah i'm sure i've seen it i've seen it
at least one of them that's the one
where they wake up in the underworld
and uh bruce lee it's about
bruce lee in the underworld no no that's
some
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] the name that's a
good one god damn it
the third leg of bruce lee yeah that's
not legend of the seven golden vampire
is that some [ __ ] what the [ __ ] was the
name of that we might have even done a
review on he fought dracula
yeah it was dry there was mummies yeah
he
yeah he fought directly who else did he
fight you fought uh [ __ ]
laurel and hardy was in it wasn't el was
elvis no no no
um clint eastwood clinton he fought
glenn eastwood was in there
yeah just [ __ ] was frankenstein but
no
[ __ ] man i know i can't remember i think
frankenstein was in there
everybody else was hit there yeah why
can't i remember the name of that
[ __ ] movie
i feel it didn't have like a really fun
title
no it's ridiculous i remember when we
watched that because we were kind of
drinking we watched it and like i was on
facebook and i was talking to somebody
and i kept like posting updates about it
because i was just like oh and now there
are mummies
yeah and it's just like a dude's like
covered with toilet paper and [ __ ] yeah
the [ __ ] was the name of that [ __ ] i
don't remember
i can't remember the name of it but yeah
it definitely wasn't like it was bruce
playtation
it was yeah it was a bruce playtation
yeah it was good though it's like one of
the best of the
bruce boy we had a [ __ ] blast
watching that movie if we can remember
what the [ __ ] name of it is
then we'll maybe we can do a review on
it if we haven't already it was
subtitled and it wasn't really
i think it was subtitled wouldn't it
yeah and it was
really clear subtit it was that we were
seeing because we didn't know any
chinese folklore
we didn't realize that it was bruce lee
in the underworld
yeah because it was a totally different
dude that didn't look anything like
didn't look anything like bruce lee and
then bruce lee fights a dude who looks
just like bruce lee and they were like
why would he why didn't that bite guy be
yeah they even mentioned it in the movie
why aren't you bruce lee
yeah [ __ ] ridiculous or they
mentioned it because they said
that dude would play bruce lee in other
bruce lee rip-off movies yeah
it was like bruce lie like yeah because
there were a lot of there was there was
like a bruce lee with one e yeah it was
bruce lee with
her eyes yeah
it's just it's so funny it's like so
shameless
yeah you know what i mean it just seems
like it's so tacky but it's like it's
[ __ ] hilarious
man they did what they wanted well
they're just like well bruce lee we got
bruce lee for you yeah they were like
they they were like well he died and
it's like he only made like four movies
and he's super famous like around the
world it's like [ __ ] what are we gonna
do
but that movie we're talking about
actually had bruce lee it didn't have
pictures of him in his coffin i think it
might have happened
during his funeral and [ __ ] there's ten
yes it did it was that's what i mean
it's like totally shacky as [ __ ] that
guy real no what they said
why the guy that played bruce lee like
in the after world like in the movie
why they said it didn't look like him
was because when you die
you can come back looking like a totally
different [ __ ] yeah okay
which they they did like address it yeah
but like i said that's what we thought
was weird because then later he fights
this dude
that looks almost exactly like bruce lee
and i'm like i don't
he was impersonating bruce lee in other
movies i guess and he's like why didn't
they get that guy to be the main
character because the main character
looked
nothing like bruce lee but yeah like
it's the [ __ ] craziest [ __ ] ever like
i said there's mummies in it
there's yeah there's clint eastwood with
the poncho
it uh [ __ ] man with laurel and hardy was
in it right or the keystone cops or
something like that right i can't even
remember there were so
many like people wandering around the
afterlife
the godfather the godfather was in it
yes
he fights the godfather with kung fu
yeah yeah ridiculous
it's a ridiculous ridiculous movie
hernandez i remember those movies i wish
i could remember this was the craziest
one i ever saw
they'd play them [ __ ] all day long
[ __ ] saturday afternoon
[ __ ] california in the local channels
[ __ ] bruce lee rip-off movies
yeah i mean not a single movie with real
bruce lee in it but
he didn't make that with the fake bruce
lee he didn't make that
bruce lee theater saturday [ __ ] yeah
[Laughter]
ridiculous but uh yeah so do we have
anything else we need to add i mean
you can't really talk about the movie's
plot or anything you know what i mean
it's not that
wasn't the point of the movie yeah i
mean the plot's kind of complicated
but it is but it doesn't you don't care
watching it it's just him
one fight after another all you have to
really all you have to know is that all
the bad guys are coming after him and
his friends
and they have to save this little girl
that's pretty much i mean there's a lot
of other [ __ ] going on too but
i give it four and a half out of five
stars it was it was really good fun to
watch yeah
and uh yeah like i said now if you're
not it's because it's real gory and it's
real
violent so um you know if that's going
to bother you kind of took me back it's
and it had a lot of it had a good score
to it
it in certain parts it was getting new
retro wave trying to do like an updated
80s
score and then when the when the fake
lesbians were fighting it went [ __ ]
goth industrial
and it changed and it changed the score
so it all fit
fit what you were seeing it was a good
job yeah
really good but uh yes yeah at least um
in the us it's on netflix i assume
that it uh is on netflix and other
territories as well because netflix
picked up the
entire distribution so i imagine that if
you're in another country you can look
at netflix and see if it's
channel 9 hong kong theater i think
that's what it was called yeah channel
9.
in california oracle says anybody else
remember the weekend movie series the
sons of hercules
that sounds vaguely familiar i remember
like mystery science theater making some
jokes about that
which is maybe why that sounds familiar
to me because they did a bunch of like
shitty hercules movies on hong kong
theater
louie i remember that there was one it
[ __ ] traumatized the [ __ ] out of me
when i was a kid
they had all these different kung fu
masters and one of them had a thing that
looked like a damn round frisbee with a
bunch of damn
teeth and spikes on it oh yeah and it
was on a chain
and he could throw it and it would
[ __ ] hit you in the top of the head
and
come around like a basket and then he
could pull it back and cut your head off
you need to have your head in a damn
basket handy
yeah that's almost like something you'd
see an infomercial yeah the way they had
it edited it scared the [ __ ] out of me
because it's like
wink you know side effects and then the
body's just standing there at the head
gone
yeah it looked
[Laughter]
but when you're a kid you're like whoa
[Laughter]
i don't know if you remember that one
man yeah the old hercules movies back
and
a lot of them had like steve reeves in
them a couple of them had uh
mickey hargitay who was married to uh
what's her face jane mansfield
um there were some other ones too i
can't remember the name of the other
dude that was in them
but yeah like like i said on mystery
science theater they did a bunch of
those like
cheap jack like italian hercules movies
and they're uh pretty entertaining
here's something i don't know why i just
thought of this but this is something
that comes up in a lot of the hercules
movies and i was wondering if this is a
thing because
i used to read a lot of greek mythology
and this was like nothing that ever
uh nothing that i ever came across in
almost all these movies
hercules thing it's like a running gag
that he's
like sleeping all the time yeah you know
what i mean
like they're always like making a joke
so he's sleeping again that's like all
he does is [ __ ] sleep
so i don't really i don't i don't really
know if that's like a thing that
hercules does but they put it in the
movies all the time but i don't know why
louis says he remembers the movie with
the damn head frisbee
yeah cutting off yeah it was about
somebody i mean didn't one of the james
bond
villains have the hat with the blade
around that yeah yeah but this wasn't a
hat it was like a yeah like a frisbee
it's like a frisbee and i guess it i
don't remember if it had
blades on the outside i know it had some
on the inside i think it might have had
them on the outside too when you pulled
on a chain they went to the inside and
cut your head off
something like that but um it's about
somebody and
who recruited an army of different kinds
of
specialist kung fu specialist each one
of them had a different weapon
that was the gimmick okay and i guess
they were the bad guys
and of course you know it's always the
same thing some poor
peasant country boy who you know he's
tough he's like this you know
yeah yeah and he has to fight these you
know six or seven
[ __ ] with like vastly superior
weapons
yes [ __ ] yeah and each one of them is
you know like dude they can throw
poison darts or another dude with a
decapitation
head machine another dude that can you
know
shoot fire from his hands you know just
stupid [ __ ] like that yeah
you know how they were i just remembered
the damn head cutting off frisbee
i think if i if i had back he had your
head in a basket
because yeah i'm going to keep that one
yeah it was like a ring
oh like tupperware like kind of like
listen what i'm saying
he's getting remember the [ __ ] old
frisbees that we had that were like
rings
that's the first thing that reminded me
of okay it's like a ring
and i think it had jagged teeth like
blades on the outside of it it was
attached to a chain
and it had a top but with an accordion
it would expand like an accordion and
he'd throw it like a frisbee and it
could stick into you
or if it went over your head he could do
something and it would land on your head
and it would fall
and then go and then he'd pull it back
and it wouldn't the blades would go in
and cut your head off and heavier and
then it would come in the back
in the basket ingenious yeah and when he
first shows up in the movie
he demonstrates that he does it to a
couple of guys and they're going to
stay out there got the job you got the
job you know
dude it'll be fine did it to his [ __ ]
he did it to the dude's soldiers you
know if
show me what you can do you know oh he
pulls off two [ __ ]
of his own soldier's heads and he's like
oh okay yeah you got the job you know
just you know how crazy
it was i'm just i'm imagining an
infomercial for that
that's why i'm laughing yeah you know of
course you know and that's not all
the old dudes the big white [ __ ]
mustaches and the big old long white
beard in the long white hair he's in
charge of everything
well yeah of course he could fly you
know [ __ ]
shot he could jump
you know yeah i guess i will teach you
my chi flying ability
yes you will move slow like a lizard
climb like a salamander jumping
like a like a frog yeah
yeah with the hands of the salamander
just [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] when you're a
kid you're buying that [ __ ]
you're like yeah yeah i could yeah
mystical eating i want to have the
hands
well they can do it of course they can
do it they're chinese you know that's
the way we used to think you know
you know chinese people can do it that's
why we were talking about that on our
gremlins river that like
if it was from china it was from another
[ __ ] planet because i was sitting
there saying it's like don't aren't you
guys like alarmed like this is a totally
different species it's like
has human intelligence they're like it's
vaginas you know
it's back when i thought you know a
[ __ ] 110 pound chinese guy could
easily beat a [ __ ] 200 pound white
dudes and just beat his ass
you know because he was fast you know
until i
till i found out that if a [ __ ]
can pick you up he's got you
yeah not a lot you can do if they can
just kind of pick you up by the scruff
of your neck and then you're just kind
of like
yeah that's why children don't whip
adulter's ass
you know that's why that happens the
[ __ ] can pick you up forget it
i tried i tried
no you don't have any leverage to get a
blow in yeah you'd be like suspended
being suspended in water trying to punch
somebody yeah
if you had your feet up against the side
of the pool maybe you could get some
force
right but if he's got you off the ground
is that's it yeah like i said you could
just kind of
get right like you can't get any
strength
don't [ __ ] with dudes that are really
big okay if they're much bigger
that's your tip size is a factor
size is a factor don't tell them
chinese guys that though
evidently martial arts negates that you
know
well yeah not mic they can do magical
[ __ ] yeah
they can do magical [ __ ] they can go
they can like do the chee ball and they
can like [ __ ] knock your head off you
know
yeah but yeah so uh you got anything
else you'd like that
is it uh hello willow anne pixie she
says she's new here
okay so hi there hi
we do this five days a week and
got all the regulars here like talking
about kung fu movies
yeah so this is on netflix like i said
if you like kung fu movies and you like
really really gory
graphic ones you get to see people's
like heads and arms and [ __ ] flying off
and all kind of [ __ ] like left people
stabbed and fallen out of windows and
whatnot
then you'll probably really be really
into this i thought it was super fun
um yeah so you're done yeah all right so
uh we'll be back tomorrow
uh i have one movie planned i'm not sure
if we're gonna be able to watch it or
not but
if not i'll find another one so uh we'll
be back tomorrow same time
same channel thanks for dropping by
everybody we'll see you tomorrow
bye